[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
but for a few inches neither of us would
be here today an ex-correction officer
now behind bars himself we'll take you
to the sentencing of the ohio man and
show you the shocking video as he shoots
at a deputy plus
hello hello and good morning
it is really nice and sunny today a 22
year old woman vanishes from a
cross-country road trip with her
boyfriend the surprising location where
the couple's van was found and the jury
is now deliberating in the robert durst
trial here they heated back and forth
between durst's prosecution and the
trial judge now you are treading on
on ice thin ice but first federal
charges against derrick chauvin
convicted murderer of the late george
floyd the ex-police officer's plea
before a federal court law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmart along with terry
austin we begin with a major update in
the federal prosecution for the death of
george floyd for minnesota police
officer derek shovin and three other
ex-officers are pleading not guilty to
federal civil rights charges
chopin and the other ex-officers two tau
j alexander king and thomas lane made
their appearance in federal court on
tuesday in minnesota they're facing
charges of depriving george floyd of his
constitutional rights back in may of
2020. in june of this year sheldon was
sentenced to 22 and a half years in
prison in connection to the murder of
george floyd on tuesday shoving appeared
in court virtually from oak park heights
correctional facility his three former
colleagues all appeared in person and
are out on twenty five thousand dollar
bond in a separate incident chauvin is
also accused of holding a 14 year old
boy by the throat and hitting him
multiple times in the head with a
flashlight a federal hearing is
scheduled on thursday where chauvin will
be arraigned for that separate incident
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin bernard one of the many motions
argued today was that the three officers
should have a separate trial from shovin
they were successful in the state case
will they be here
so brian it's going to be a lot of
arguments in regards to having a
separate trial obviously it benefits
each of the officers formal officers if
their trials were severed from each
other because you're not going to have
so much damage evidence in terms of
everything and every last bit of what
derek chalvin do now i don't know if
they're going to be successful though
with the federal case because one thing
that they have to determine the judge is
going to have to determine is that are
there statements against any one of
these officers that they actually made
against each other that will require
them to have a separate trial so that is
going to be one of the elements that's
going to be evaluated heavily to make
that determination yeah it's not quite
sure whether or not there's an
antagonistic defense which make it
easier to separate
terry with shogun surfing time on the
state case two federal cases against him
coming up and a tax evasion case should
we expect pleas or trials from him
you know brian this could go either way
he's going to be in jail in any case for
you know 22 and a half years because
he's already been convicted of the
murder of george floyd but his other two
federal cases and this tax case really
do present some complicated problems for
him and i think he's going to have to
coordinate things we already heard that
there was some talk before failed talk
about a plea deal we could hear about
that again but my view is if that plea
deal fails and he doesn't reach an
agreement with the prosecution on the
federal cases either one of them the
2020 george floyd or the 14 year old boy
i think he's going to fight and i think
he's going to fight hard he could
probably settle the tax claim yeah we
know he was trying to get his time
served in a federal penitentiary rather
than state as many officers do when
they're sentenced maybe that may be the
crux to taking a plea or going to trial
we'll check it out later turning now to
ohio where a man who tried to kill a
sheriff's deputy learns his punishment
law and crime's angela levy shows us the
video of the incident and what the
deputy says about nearly being killed
a doorbell camera recorded this incident
at a home outside of cincinnati back in
february warren county sheriff's deputy
sarah vaught narrowly escaped being
killed
deputy vaught and others went to the
home of 57 year old lance runyon
checking on him at the request of family
members since the shooting vott says she
has been diagnosed with post-traumatic
stress disorder she says she still
doesn't understand why lance runyon
tried to kill her
i have dealt with hundreds of people in
crisis during my 12 years on patrol
intoxicated people suicidal people
people in psychosis people whose
children i am taking away people who
have committed terrible crimes and are
facing long prison sentences people who
were all of those things at the same
time
and lance runyon is the only one that
has tried to kill me
runyon is an ex-corrections officer and
teacher with no criminal record his
attorney says he doesn't remember the
incident deputies shot runyon and then
raced to help him he spoke briefly
before learning his punishment
i'm sorry happened not because i'm in
trouble but because for everybody a
judge sentenced lance runyon to a total
of 17 years in prison for law and crime
daily i'm angenette levy
thank you anjanet turning now to the
east coast where the first trial is
underway in the so-called operation
varsity blues scandal it alleges parents
bought their children's acceptance
letters into top universities
the case rose to fame in 2019 after
upwards of 50 people were arrested for
their involvement notably celebrities
lori laughlin and felicity huffman were
convicted for participating in the
scheme that traded thousands of dollars
for their child's admissions to college
officials say that between 2011 and 2018
parents doled out 25 million dollars to
admissions consultant rick singer the
mastermind behind the conspiracy singer
then used some of those funds to bribe
college officials flood test scores and
create fictional collegiate sports
recruits the trial opened on monday in
boston's federal court where the
defendants a former casino executive and
former gap co claimed that they were
duped by singer believing their
donations were going directly to the
universities the trial is expected to
last several weeks
still ahead on law and crime daily famed
r b singer r kelly on trial in a federal
arena we'll break down the gripping
testimony but first elizabeth holmes
back in court the unexpected break from
the federal case against a former
billionaire still ahead
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back the federal case against
elizabeth holmes was back in session
tuesday after a brief recess due to a
juror's exposure to copenhagen in
tuesday's testimony former theronos
employees detailed the hundreds of
millions of dollars the company lost
over the years
holmes faces 12 fraud charges stemming
from her times as ceo of theranos the
stanford dropout founded the company at
age 19 claiming it would revolutionize
blood testing but later investigations
found there were many issues with that
process last week the trial was put on
hold after a drawer voice concerned
about a coven 19 exposure this week the
juror took back to back negative coveted
tests with court back in session the
jury heard from a former theronos
controller who said the company deficit
ran upwards of
376 million dollars by 2014. tuesday
marked day two of testimony in the trial
that is expected to last for weeks
switching gears now to the sex
trafficking trial against r kelly the
federal trial continues with more
testimony from uncharted accusers and
employees of the disgraced king of rmb
before testimony began there was a major
ruling in the government's favor that
may lead the jury to hear from r kelly
without him taking the stand the judge
ruled that pieces of a video and audio
recording will come in with r kelly
berating jane doe 20 for allegedly
stealing from r kelly in the recordings
he screams if you lie to me i'm going to
f you up but as the prosecution tried to
admit the recordings into evidence jane
doe 20 had a panic attack now the
government says that for the sake of her
mental health they would not call her
back as a witness in the trial then
another jane doe angela testified that
along with being sexually abused by the
singer as a teenager she also walked in
on r kelly giving oral sex to then
teenager aaliyah testimony that went to
show the continued sexual abuse of
minors by the r b singer the second male
accuser who testified as alex but r
kelly nicknamed nephew told the brooklyn
federal jury of the sexual relationship
he and r kelly shared alex explained
that he met kelly through the first male
accuser lewis when he was 16 and he too
was part of kelly's basketball crew but
his relationship did not become sexual
teddy was 20 when kelly pushed himself
onto alex saying have an open mind from
there alex testified that he and kelly
would have sexual encounters often with
women that he did not know and looked
zombie-ish r kelly would allegedly
record alex and the women having sex to
his instructions sometimes he would just
watch and other times he would join the
defense pushed back on alex's testimony
asking why he simply told federal
authorities he worked for r kelly before
defense attorney deborah ocanick could
cut him off alex said he had been
brainwashed for so long
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney bernardo violona and co-host
terry austin terry in what has been
described as an emotional breakdown jane
bill 20 will not be called to testify
again does this mean the video and audio
recording won't be played for the jury
the video and audio should be played
brian there's no question about that i
think it will be admitted into evidence
they only need to show two things that
it was authenticated and that there was
the chain of custody from the beginning
of the creation of the video the
authentication authentication has to
show
someone who was in the video to
really basically say that it depicts who
it purports to show and so if they can
get uncle george who apparently was
there or an engineer they won't need
jane doe number 20 and the chain of
custody should be fairly easy to
establish from the origins of the tape
and then when it was subpoenaed and when
it was located and the transmission of
the tape subsequent to that so i think
they should be able to get it into
evidence absolutely maybe we'll see some
last-minute subpoenas to do just as you
described
terry because that seems to be the best
route for the government now bernard
control over jane does john does and his
employees what does alex and angela's
testimony give to the prosecution in
terms of an enterprise under the rico
act so brian what we've heard from from
these last couple of weeks from these
women from who were teenagers at the
time as well as from males that were
teenagers at the time what it has proven
and has shown is that r kelly had a
decades decades of predatory behavior
and it did not just exist with young
female girls but also with males what
this has gone to show and what is so
troubling to me brian is a testimony
that we heard from yesterday from angela
that she said that poor aliyah that we
all have come to know from growing up
with her music that she walked into the
room and when she walked into the room
she saw this grown man r kelly in his
20s performing oral sex on aaliyah who
was between the ages of 12 and 14 at the
time what that testimony did is that it
solidified the rico act rico act number
one that pertains to aaliyah in this
case but brian i mean all this testimony
that we're receiving you see the same
pattern same pattern same pattern and
that's the control that r kelly
exercised over his employees all these
young girls over these guys and that
they were all scared of doing anything
different to disobey this predator
absolutely thank you for that bernarda
and terry coming up on law and crime
daily the jury enters deliberation in
the trial of california vs robert durst
plus a new york woman missing for weeks
after a trip across the country with her
boyfriend the last video she posted to
her social media before she ventured
[Music]
welcome back on to our top legal news a
nationwide search is underway for a
missing 22 year old woman after she left
for a cross-country road trip with her
boyfriend
i think our plan for today is to just
hang out
here in the tent
um
buying stretching
doing some
morning yoga officials say gabrielle
petito of suffolk county new york is
believed to have been at grand teton
national park in wyoming she detailed
her trip with a video posted to youtube
showing her traveling with a man named
brian in a white van
officials say the van was found in
florida at her boyfriend's parents home
police say he was not missing but did
not say where he is or whether he may be
involved in the disappearance petito's
mother says she last received text
messages from petito at the end of
august but can't confirm it was her
because she didn't speak via the phone
potito is described as being a white
woman with blonde hair 5 feet 5 inches
tall and about 110 pounds anyone with
more information should contact crime
stoppers the number is at the bottom of
your screen
and in new hampshire crucial updates for
the family of maura murray who went
missing back in 2004. murray was seen by
motorists after she crashed her car in
february 2004 the police initially
treated it as a missing person's case
before handing it over to the new
hampshire cold case division 17 years
later her family reported bone fragments
found at a popular ski resort in the
area to law enforcement testing is
currently being done to the discovered
bone fragments as the investigation
remains to be ongoing
an update now in the story we've been
following singer rod stewart will avoid
jail time as a florida judge cancels his
trial and scheduled a plea hearing
instead the trial was set to begin
tuesday in florida you may remember
stuart and his adult son sean stewart
face charges of battery stemming from a
2019 altercation authorities say stewart
and his son were involved in a physical
fight with a security guard on new
year's eve of that year last week
stewart's can't reach a deal with
prosecutors the famed maggie may singer
and his son are expected to appear in a
final hearing late october
on to texas where police say a shocking
murder-suicide took place in the lobby
of a houston hotel police say
27-year-old jenna sonderberg was shot
and killed by her long-time boyfriend
39-year-old sherick bird at a marriott
marquis on september 7th witnesses say
they saw the couple arrive at the hotel
and heard gunshots just moments later
officials believe the pair were planning
to check into the hotel at the time of
the shooting according to court
documents sonderberg had filed multiple
reports between 2018 and 2019 alleging
bird was physically abusive
when we come back the jury heads to
deliberation in the trial of california
versus robert durst we'll hear the
heated back and forth between the judge
and the prosecution all that and more
next
[Music]
welcome back after months in the
courtroom the jury is finally
deliberating the fate of accused
murderer and real estate heir robert
durst
durst is on trial for the murder of his
best friend susan berman who was
discovered with a bullet wound in her
head in her benedict canyon home back in
2000. the real estate airs trial has
been ongoing for nearly four months
after previously being paused for the
pandemic the defense wrapped up their
closing arguments on monday but before
court resumed prosecutor john lewin
voiced his opinion on evidence from
durst galveston trial where he was
acquitted of the murder of his neighbor
morris black in a heated back and forth
the judge snapped back at the prosecutor
now here's the problem your honor he
does not have the legal right or the
authority or the position as an attorney
to tell the jury that evidence that the
court has admitted was admitted
improperly and that's what he said
that's number one number two i i really
i take it to mean it was presented for
that reason not that it was not that i
admitted it for that reason because he
should be attacking me
you can if you want to twist his words
to to come up with an innocent intent if
you want us basically say mr
mr lewin do not say that the court is
twisting a party's words now you are
treading on
on ice thin ice well your honor i'm
trying to make
my point is simple he says in my opinion
based on the evidence galveston
shouldn't be admitted in this case
as the defense wrapped up their closing
argument they addressed perhaps the
biggest elephant in the room the
testimony from one of robert durst's
closest friends nick chavin who claims
that durst confessed to murdering susan
berman saying quote it was her or me i
had no choice
i want i want to leave you with the
following
i want i want you to imagine
that one of your relatives is very sick
in the hospital
and they're basically on life support
and a decision has to be made
as to whether or not
you say enough is enough you're going to
rely heavily on what the doctor says
and you walk into the room to talk to
the doctor
and the doctor is nick chavin
would you rely on nick chavin
to decide that important issue in your
life
or would you run from the hospital room
following the state's closing arguments
prosecutor john lewin began his rebuttal
pointing out all of the evidence that
his team has presented
about the only thing that we have not
given you in this case is literally a
videotape
of the murder
it's about the only thing we haven't
given you um
defense as well you don't have any
physical evidence
what physical evidence would you expect
what are you going to get bob durst goes
in very likely wearing gloves and
executes her in the back of the head and
leaves
he's admitted that he was touching
phones etc and there's no fingerprints
what does that mean the only reasonable
inference is he's wearing gloves you
would expect him to be wearing gloves
because bob durst went down there
knowing exactly what he was going to do
lewin seemed to have this case all
wrapped up with the judge but could this
skating on thin ice affect the trial
well what we're hoping one is that none
of this has been done in front of the
jury because you don't want the jury to
be affected by the back and forth and
sometimes being disrespectful to the
judge let that affect their decision
making in this case but you got to think
that they've been going on at it for
months months they have such a close
relationship because they've spent so
many hours together so i think people
are getting underneath each other's skin
but you gotta remember in the end that
judge window he's the judge
exactly terry during lewin's rebuttal he
mentioned the witnesses the witness
killing special circumstances charge do
you think he explained it well enough to
the jury
i do and it was a good idea that he did
these special circumstance allegations
of killing of witness and also of lying
and weight had to be explained because
most people think a witness is someone
who witnessed a murder but here it means
someone who would have been a witness in
the prosecution of the case and lewin
also explained that lying in weight
doesn't necessarily mean you have to be
behind a closed door it just means that
you are trying to hide the circumstances
and the fact that you have this
murderous intent so good explanation by
luanne yeah and probably one that needed
to be made because it's not just a plain
language there's a little bit more than
that thank you both and thank you for
joining us here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you